that night after the premiere and at the
after party i
collapsed and that was something that's
happened frequently in my life
elliot page is getting candid about the
pressures he faced over the years before
coming out
as transgender in his sit-down interview
with oprah winfrey for apple tv's the
oprah conversation
the oscar-nominated actor reveals how
much his mental health was affected
by the expectations he felt he needed to
meet due to gender pressures
to the outside world it looks like whoa
this is what you want in your life
you know the the trajectory of your
career
continuing to rise rise rise i mean
always always being offered roles in
these
you know iconic blockbuster films
you reconstructed all of this from
memory like i told you we had lots of
time
the period where i was shooting and
promoting inception but
promoting inception i'd say because
there was
so much press so many premieres all
around the world
and i was wearing you know dresses and
heels
to pretty much every
single um event elliott recalls an
incident that occurred during the press
tour for inception in 2010
involving his manager that made him
reach a breaking point
we had just finished all the like press
and like jess had the premiere that
night
and my manager who's like family to me
and we're so close and she couldn't be
more supportive
and incredible but there used to be a
lot of
you know tension back then but
she really believed she was helping me
doing the right thing for me like
helping my career by encouraging the
the dresses and the heels and the sort
of pressure to do that but we got back
to the room
and she was like i have a surprise
and like i already had to wear the dress
had one picked out and i went in and
there were three dresses laid out
like new dresses to maybe see and i
just like i like
i lost it elliott goes on to reveal he
suffered a panic attack
and even collapsed due to that pressure
i got
so it was
like a cinematic moment you know like
the kind of like
thing that would be in a movie where you
know
and that night after the premiere and at
the after party i
collapsed and that was something that's
happened frequently in my life usually
corresponding with a panic attack
during the interview elliott reveals he
also had similar experiences
on the press tour for 2007's juno and
while attending the oscars
where he was nominated for his role in
the film but since coming out in
december
the umbrella academy star shares that he
now feels a great responsibility in
sharing his truth
so much of the privilege i have the
ability to
be here sitting here right now is really
because of so many
trans women of color who have
consistently put their lives on the line
throughout history
i'm grateful to have the access to the
resources i've
i've had because i don't know what would
have happened if
i didn't i don't know how to really say
it other than it just
feels more important than
feeling scared in moments it feels more
important than
if i have an overwhelming day
it to me s really simply feels like
absolutely the right thing to do
you